- [Instructor] Let's say we have
a 0.20 Molar aqueous
solution of acidic acid.
And our goal is to calculate the pH
and the percent ionization.
The Ka value for acidic acid
is equal to 1.8 times
10 to the negative fifth
at 25 degrees Celsius.
First, we need to write out
the balanced equation showing
the ionization of acidic acid.
So acidic acid reacts with
water to form the hydronium ion,
H3O+,
and acetate, which is the
conjugate base to acidic acid.
Because acidic acid is a weak acid,
it only partially ionizes.
Therefore, we need to set up an ICE table
so we can figure out
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ion,
which will allow us to calculate the pH
and the percent ionization.
In an ICE table, the I stands
for initial concentration,
C is for change in concentration,
and E is equilibrium concentration.
The initial concentration of
acidic acid is 0.20 Molar.
So we can put that in our
ICE table under acidic acid.
And if we assume that the
reaction hasn't happened yet,
the initial concentrations
of hydronium ion
and acetate anion would both be zero.
Some of the acidic acid will ionize,
but since we don't know how much,
we're gonna call that x.
So we write -x under acidic acid
for the change part of our ICE table.
And when acidic acid reacts with water,
we form hydronium and acetate.
So we're going to gain in
the amount of our products.
To figure out how much
we look at mole ratios
from the balanced equation.
There's a one to one mole ratio
of acidic acid to hydronium ion.
Therefore, if we write -x for acidic acid,
we're gonna write +x under hydronium.
And for the acetate
anion, there's also a one
as a coefficient in the balanced equation.
Therefore, we can write
+x under acetate as well.
So the equilibrium
concentration of acidic acid
would be 0.20 minus x.
Let's go ahead and write that in here,
0.20 minus x.
The equilibrium concentration of hydronium
would be zero plus x, which is just x.
And for acetate, it would
also be zero plus x,
so we can just write x here.
Next, we brought out the
equilibrium constant expression,
which we can get from
the balanced equation.
So the Ka is equal to the concentration
of the hydronium ion.
And since there's a coefficient of one,
that's the concentration
of hydronium ion raised
to the first power,
times the concentration
of the acetate anion
also raised to the first power,
divided by the concentration
of acidic acid raised to the first power.
And water is left out of
our equilibrium constant expression.
Because the concentrations
in our equilibrium constant expression
or equilibrium concentrations,
we can plug in what we
have from our ICE table.
So we can plug in x for the
equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ion,
x is also the equilibrium concentration
of the acetate anion,
and 0.20 minus x is the
equilibrium concentration
of acidic acid.
We also need to plug in the
Ka value for acidic acid
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Here we have our equilibrium
concentrations plugged in
and also the Ka value.
Our goal is to solve for x,
which would give us the
equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions.
However, if we solve for x here,
we would need to use a quadratic equation.
So to make the math a little bit easier,
we're gonna use an approximation.
We're gonna say that 0.20 minus x
is approximately equal to 0.20.
The reason why we can
make this approximation
is because acidic acid is a weak acid,
which we know from its Ka value.
Ka is less than one.
And that means it's only
going to partially ionize.
It's going to ionize
to a very small extent,
which means that x must
be a very small number.
And if x is a really small
number compared to 0.20,
0.20 minus x is approximately
just equal to 0.20.
So we can go ahead and rewrite this.
So we would have 1.8 times
10 to the negative fifth
is equal to x squared over,
and instead of 0.20 minus x,
we're just gonna write 0.20.
Solving for x, we would
find that x is equal to 1.9,
times 10 to the negative third.
And remember, this is equal to
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions.
So let's write in here,
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions.
So this is 1.9 times 10 to
the negative third Molar.
If we would have used the
quadratic equation to solve for x,
we would have also gotten 1.9
times 10 to the negative third
to two significant figures.
Therefore, using the approximation
got us the same answer
and saved us some time.
Also, now that we have a value for x,
we can go back to our approximation
and see that x is very
small compared to 0.20.
So 0.20 minus x is
approximately equal to 0.20.
Also, this concentration of hydronium ion
is only from the
ionization of acidic acid.
And it's true that
there's some contribution
of hydronium ion from the
autoionization of water.
However, that concentration
is much smaller than this.
So for this problem, we
can ignore the contribution
of hydronium ions from the
autoionization of water.
Next, we can find the pH of our solution
at 25 degrees Celsius.
So pH is equal to the negative
log of the concentration
of hydronium ions.
So that's the negative log of 1.9 times 10
to the negative third,
which is equal to 2.72.
We also need to calculate
the percent ionization.
So the equation 4% ionization is equal to
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions,
divided by the initial
concentration of the acid,
times 100%.
The equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions
is equal to 1.9 times 10
to negative third Molar.
So we plug that in.
And the initial concentration
of our weak acid,
which was acidic acid is 0.20 Molar.
So the Molars cancel,
and we get a percent ionization of 0.95%.
A low value for the percent
ionization makes sense
because acidic acid is a weak acid.
We can also use the percent
ionization to justify
the approximation that
we made earlier using
what's called the 5% rule.
So let me write that
down here, the 5% rule.
If the percent ionization is less than 5%
as it was in our case, it
was less than 1% actually,
then the approximation is valid.
If the percent ionization
is greater than 5%,
then the approximation is not valid
and you have to use
the quadratic equation.